RUSSIA INVESTIGATION IT’S TERNL.
A CONSTANT FORCE IN OUR LIVES
A FACT OF PHYSICS IN WASHINGTON,
THAT APPARENTLY WILL NEVER GO
AWAY.
WE’RE POWERLESS IN HIS FACE.
WE’RE ALL DISTRACTED BY BRETT
KAVANAUGH, DOESN’T MEAN THAT
RUSSIA IS NO LONGER BEING
INVESTIGATED.
WE SHOULD BE AFRAID, THEY HACKED
OUR ELECTION.
FOX NEWS CAN NOW REPORT IN 2016,
MICHAEL SUSMAN, TOP LAWYER WITH
THE DNC IN THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, CONTACTED THE FBI AND
PROVIDED RUSH WHY-RELATED
DOCUMENTS.
THE DOCUMENTS WERE TURNED OVER
JUST AS THE BUREAU WAS PREPARING
A SURVEILLANCE WARRANT AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS
SPYING ON HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
TOM, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
TELL US WHAT THIS MEANS.
>> WELL, IT BRINGS THE COLLUSION
STORY, LOOK, THE LAW FIRM WAS A
CUTOUT, ORIGINALLY, FOR THE
CLINTON OPERATION, PERKINS, TO
PAY FUSION GPS.
AFTER A WHILE THEY SAID, WHY
PRETEND ANY MORE, DEAL DIRECTLY
WITH OUR FRIENDS IN THE OBAMA
FBI TO TARGET PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT’S JUST ANOTHER PIECE OF
EVIDENCE OF THE COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE OBAMA CAMP AND THE
CLINTON CAMP.
AND THERE’S NO EVIDENCE COMING
OUT OF COLLUSION BETWEEN TRUMP
AND RUSSIA.
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE IS THAT WE
WERE USING THE FBI TO LAUNDER
POLITICAL GARBAGE AS AN EXCUSE
TO TARGET PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS
ROBERT MUELLER DOING WITH THIS
MATERIAL?
IS HE USING THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
MATERIAL ON TARGET TRUMP AS
WELL?
>> Tucker: I GUESS WE’RE GOING
TO FIND OUT.
I HAVE TO WONDER ABOUT THE FBI.
THERE’S A LOT WE DON’T KNOW, I
DON’T WANT TO ATTACK PEOPLE
UNFAIRLY.
IF YOU ARE THE FBI AND ONE
CAMPAIGN COMES TO YOU WITH
OPPOSITION RESEARCH ABOUT THE
OTHER CAMPAIGN, DON’T YOU PAUSE
AND SAY, WAIT A SECOND, I DON’T
WANT TO GET CAUGHT UP IN SOME
KIND OF CAMPAIGN TACTIC IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PRESIDENTIAL YEAR?
DOESN’T THAT MAKE YOU NERVOUS,
IF YOU’RE THE FBI?
>> IT OUGHT TO.
LOOK, THERE’S NO GOOD REASON FOR
THE GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE FBI
TO BE MEETING WITH A TOP LAWYER
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE AND THE HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THE MEETING ITSELF WAS UNUSUAL.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE WAS
ALLEGEDLY TRANSFER OF
INFORMATION ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
AND RUSSIA.
WE KNOW THE INFORMATION THAT
GENERALLY HAD BEEN PUSHED BY THE
CLINTON OPERATION, WAS, REALLY,
STUFF MADE UP BY RUSSIA
INTELLIGENCE, TO MESS WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
SO, FAKE INFORMATION, USED FOR
PARTISAN PURPOSES.
THE FBI WAS HAPPY TO USE IT AS A
PRETEXT TO TARGET TRUMP.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, THIS DEBATE
WHETHER THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND THE FBI AND
D.O.J. BEING NERVOUS ABOUT THAT,
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY REASONS,
WELL I SUSPECT THIS IS WHY
THEY’RE NERVOUS.
THIS IS A TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT WOULD COME OUT AS A RESULT
OF A TRANSPARENCY INITIATIVE BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Tucker: JUST TO CLARIFY,
NERVOUS ABOUT DAMAGE TO THEIR
OWN REPUTATION, YOU’RE SAYING.
>> WELL, AND WORSE.
IF YOU’RE MISUSING YOUR OFFICE
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES, AS
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, IN THE
REAL WORLD, OR THE NONWASHINGTON
D.C. WORLD, YOU WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO PROSECUTION.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
THAT’S -- THANK YOU FOR